le programme twn l'amérique photos de
députés vont prendre leurs marques et
moi je
pense à l'après midi opérer la mise
moins d'une de mes petit chat et oui sa
petite chatte de maîtres bas hier
après-midi alors elle est intelligente
est allé aux nouvelles hier soir pour
mener l'enquêté et ben finalement pas de
mise bas hier soir ça sera pour
aujourd'hui ou demain pour la petite
chatte de marine le pen quand cahier en
scène veut faire cuire un crocodile du
jardin de son restaurant il n'hésite pas
à utiliser les moyens du bord une poêle
l'australien n'a pas eu peur d'affronter
serait plus de deux mètres cinquante
pour protéger les touristes présents
dans son établissement un acte dangereux
mais courageux salué sur les réseaux
sociaux pour celui que l'on appelle
désormais tout cas
je vais église
la casquette de l'ingérence
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y'a que ça
va aller ça va
je remercie aussi tous les gens toutes
les personnes
qui nous ont cassé les
c vrai parce que notre succès on leur
doit parce que je le redis
critiquer nous critiquer moi ça et moi
je suis tranquillement dans ma cage
comme un lion et vous m'amenez de la
viande donc allez-y continuer et même
pas besoin d'aller chasser la viande
arrive directement à moi donc continuer
l'année prochaine bien entendu et on
fera encore une très belle année soit je
le mange tous les arts soit jusqu où peu
de gens pas par quatre chemins voilà
c'est tout c'est la seule solution donc
j'ai pas le choix et saturent la vérité
pourrait se régaler 13
ans fait l'être humain un instinct de
survie et comme il faisait la
préhistoire mais sans les prisons rien
on serait pas là lui l'humain il n'a pas
subi par la bonne mère il s'est pas levé
un matin j'ai déjà incroyable a déjà vu
un fast food est devant nous michettes
donc là je suis en train de me
transformer en homme préhistorique quand
vous aurez compris que je me nourris de
vaud
peut-être que vous arrêterez par
l'instant
[Applaudissements]
à
saint cloud ou presque un carnage est la
prière à la
visuellement je pensais top
beaucoup je suis émerveillé c'est de
l'art moderne
aucune
vas-y mais les directions le fossé entre
eux et non non il vaut mieux même sur le
quotient
à chaque obstacle du dessert parce que
tu es focus sur l'obstacle qui sort la
balle tu vois là c'est toi tu ne sais
pas ce que tu viens de voter non
j'ai une idée pour toi
grand enseignement de ce sondage les
motifs de rupture qu'est ce qui peut
pousser un couple à se séparer
premier motif cité par les français le
manque d'hygiène et oui ça m'a surpris
mais c'est le manque d'hygiène en numéro
1 suivent les commentaires blessants et
en troisième position le manque
d'intérêt pour la vie de l'autre pour la
moitié des personnes interrogées
l'absence de sens de l'humour est
également un motif de rupture donc on
résume les amis on met du geo on les
écoute on ne la juge pas et on la fait
rire ce mois ci la coupe du monde et
didon et on va pas faire le jeu de celui
qui a la plus grosse ah non bon ah bon
c'est
le ji madame de rénal en place pour lui
dans le rouge et de noir julien dray
arnaud et non je leur ai doré
danse elle-même
[Musique]
c'est le frère de marc qu'on se fait des
trucs mais sur donateurs
j'ai désolé
délicieux c'est bien veillé jusqu'à
présent mais là c'est du grand n'importe
qui bien sûr oui oui voila je suis très
très très heureux d'être avec vous
jusqu'en 2026 vous m'avez apporté
énormément de bonheur ça chez lui encore
cette année et on écoutera toujours
qu'une seule personne parce que vous ne
former qu'une seule main du coup c'est
vous le public et vous voyez je prends
toujours en compte ce que vous dites sur
les réseaux ou un sur ce que vous pouvez
me dire dans dans la rue voilà pour
essayer de faire la meilleure émission
possible on essaiera de faire la
meilleure émission possible encore
l'année prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
foster's et bien visé ça fait trop
tranquille
jessica fidèle à elle-même fait de
nouveau une bourde parce qu'elle
parvient à casser
l'assiette décoration de niche on sera
de retour dès le 29 août pour quatre
années supplémentaires
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup d'être baptisé ont été
rapides mais c'était efficace c'est ce
qu'on me dit souvent